book committee for Thursday the 9th of
December 2021
um we're here just to consider the one
uh one report application which is the
request for written approval to hold a
fifth concert with a capacity of more
than five thousand in a 28 day period an
approval for use of the great Stone Road
entrance for the hgv access
relating to the premises license held
for Lancashire county cricket clubs
so that's the item you considering the
attendances will all be recorded on uh
Zoom
um way of introductions I'm councilor
German
um tonight at councilor's Brotherton and
wetton
we also have offices from the legal
licensing provenance
um and do we have the afternoon
yes it's Peter ash from from the Cricket
Club
you'll be presenting
uh answer any questions I think Claire
will just put the document forward so I
hope you know if anywhere you wish
um we also have a representation from
environmental health which is being
performed
um
to outline the application
and all their representatives to address
the court conditions
yeah
Witnesses May then be questioned by
themselves
in any other parties
uh
we've given an opportunity to address
the substance
representing any of their Witnesses may
be questioned by the members of the
stuff
and many other parts
there is only one representative tonight
which is the environmental health
can I ask if any if you're not speaking
directly in the meeting if you can turn
your microphones up thank you we're just
having a bit of feedback
after this request I'll ask I'll ask all
request all parties involved to
summarize
the representer or Representatives will
be given two minutes to summarize
followed by the applicant
we will also be given two minutes to
summarize
the subcommittee will then consider
their decision
and then I will announce the
determination of the application and the
reasons for the determination
this will be confirmed in writing within
five days of the hearing
now just before we start the meeting our
our legal officer needs to clarify
something to do to do with the report so
Carolina over to you yeah it was just to
mention that in the report there are two
options it mentions two options for the
um committee to consider when reaching
the decision
um and there is actually a third option
that the committee can grant consent
without any
um conditions attached and so
that means you can have uh sorry Grant
consent without conditions Grant consent
with conditions or you can reviews the
application
okay thank you Caroline
um
can I then if we uh licensing officer uh
is it Claire Whittle are you presenting
yes yes
good evening chair
um so I'm Claire Whittle I'm the um
regulatory services manager for trading
standards and Licensing and so I am
representing as a licensing officer in
this matter
um thank you chair and all the members
of the committee and this is um this
agenda item has been brought um to the
subcommittee today following a formal
request made by Lancashire County
Cricket Club and spaulbert Road Old
Trafford in terms of consent and
considerations that they would like you
to consider and Grant under their terms
of their current license
um in 2007 the premises license was
issued by Lancashire issued to
Lancashire County Cricket Club and for
the whole stadium which included
regulated entertainment and pop concerts
which is allowed for an agreed number
and type of events each year
um the current license imposes a range
of specific conditions in terms of
outdoor concerts with a capacity of more
than 5 000 and ticket holders unless
otherwise agreed in writing by the
license in authority and these include
um no more than seven days of outdoor
concerts with a capacity of more than 5
000 ticket
um holders shall be held on the license
premises in any calendar year
um and if in any calendar year seven
days of concerts with a capacity of more
than 5 000 ticket holders are held in
the license premises no more than five
days of concerts with a capacity of more
than five thousand ticket holders shall
be held on the um on the license
premises in the next succeeding calendar
year
outdoor concerts where the audience
exceeds five thousand and ticket holders
should not be held on the license
premises on more than four consecutive
days in any calendar year
if the events that for in the event that
for outdoor concerts with a capacity of
more than five thousand are held in a
28-day period starting with the date of
the first concert held in any each
period no outdoor concert with a
capacity of more than 5 000 should be
held in a 14-day period following the
date of the fourth concert without the
written consent of the licensing
Authority the committee today are asked
to consider um from for Lancashire
County Cricket Club their request for
written approval to hold that fifth
concert with a capacity of more than
five thousand in a 28 day period they
will be featured in various bands in
June 2022 The Killers Foo Fighters Red
Hot Chili Peppers and a further pop
concert over two days these will be held
on the 11th the 15th the 16th the 22nd
and the 25th of June 2022.
they're also asking for approval in
terms of their license
um in in for the use of the great Stone
Road entrance for hgv vehicles relating
to the premises license held for
Lancashire Cricket Club
um in terms of that that these this
request and for written approval and
we've they've consulted with the um
responsible authorities and um
Environmental Protection Team have
presented and presented additional
conditions
um for that approval to go ahead
um for the events being held on the in
June 2022
subsequently since those conditions were
were placed in the report and presented
and there has been a series of
discussions between Lancashire County
Cricket Club and um the public
Protection Team and regarding the
potential disturbance and noise control
which has resulted in
um Environmental Protection withdrawing
the existing conditions which they
initially put forward and and coming up
with a revised set of conditions
um
I'm happy to go through those if if
needed
um and I don't know if they've been seen
but I'll go through those so the first
one is that they want a noise management
plan for the fifth concert to be held on
Blanchard County Cricket Club in 2022
and it shall be provided to the local
Authority for approval six weeks prior
to hosting of the first concert on the
11th of June 2022 the noise management
plan shall demonstrate how premises
license conditions will be complied with
and in addition we'll incorporate the
following a methodology for enhanced
noise reduction and mitigation
techniques to reduce the potential for
cumulative noise impacts from the June
2022 concerts scheduled properties on
the Trent Bridge Walk
detailing of any mitigate mitigation
measures to address noise breakouts due
to potential absence of screening due to
the site Redevelopment works and number
two update noise modeling for events to
be held at Lancashire County Cricket
Club in 2022 is provided to the council
12 weeks prior to the date of the first
concert the noise model shall include
any changes to the structure of the
venue EG removal of the red rose Suite
which will take place in 2022
number three the updated noise model for
the venue shall be used to inform a
resident letter drop strategy which
shall be proprieted to the council for
review 12 weeks prior to the first
concert in 2022
and that's in respect of the fifth
concert going ahead in respect of the
approval for the great Stone Road
entrance number four and hgv access to
the ground between 8 A.M and 8pm but
avoiding Peak traffic periods number
five hgvs do not use the parts of great
Stone Road between Chester Road and
Talbot road but approach the ground via
Talbot Road turning either left or right
into the great Stone Road number six the
vehicles are unloaded between 8 A.M and
8 PM only in accordance with the license
and conditions and number seven
residents are informed of this change in
the unusual pre-concept letter 12 weeks
prior to the first concert in 2020 so
um therefore the subcommittee is asked
to consider the request from Lancashire
County Cricket Club and because they
they have agreed the those conditions um
alongside um Environmental Protection
and environmental health
um in terms of the concepts of the fifth
concept being held in a 28-day period
And so we're asked to consider whether
to Grant the license
um to go ahead with with no additional
conditions or to Grant the license
permission for the fifth concert with
those conditions that environmental
health have put forward and or refused
that permission and that's on both both
those different scenarios thank you
chair
thank you Mr whistle can it
um just one question from me you said at
the start of your presentation that
something had to be submitted six weeks
before
the first concert what what was that uh
that was the
um in terms of the noise management plan
um in for the fifth concert to be held
at Lancashire County Cricket Club so
um they're asking for approval for six
weeks prior to hosting of the first
concert that that noise traffic
management plan
um shall be presented
um and how the premise license
conditions will be complied with
um in addition we'll incorporate the
methodology of the noise reduction and
the mitigation techniques and to reduce
the potential for cumulative noise
impacts of the properties that are
around the Trent Bridge Walk
um and it's also wants them to detail
the mitigating measures to address noise
breakout due to the uh would there be an
absence of screening
um on the site because there will be
Redevelopment Works ongoing at the time
right but you said it was to win formal
letter that was going after 12 weeks
before yeah there'd be a letter to go
out 12 weeks prior to the first concert
um to let residents know of the the the
the the cons the fifth concept going
ahead and all the concerts that will be
happening in the in the in that week in
that those those um periods of um the
11th to the 25th of June
okay I'm still a bit confused
just to explain the timings okay
um before we do that does anybody have
any question or uh the license
no in that case I'll ask Mr Rush as the
applicant to um
to speak to his application please
yeah Claire is uh summarized that very
well
um just a couple of points from me
really is the fifth concert isn't
confirmed
um and will be subject to sales for the
first date
um but we wanted to have it in place if
the sales for the
um well it's the second day in those
series of concerts the Claire Club
engine if the sales are very strong for
that we would then go to the to that
extra date but it would be the same
artist in in two consecutive nights so
it's it's not we don't know whether
there will be a fifth concert until we
actually go on on sale we're there and
the second point you you mentioned about
uh the difference between the the six
weeks
um the reason for this is that we don't
have the information from the bands
um about the sound and the whole setup
until much nearer the time and therefore
until we've got those um final
um proposals from the band about the
sound Towers we can't put the final bits
in place for the mitigation factors
okay
anything else you'd like to say
well now I think that covers everything
the only other thing is with with the
red rose development
um the the planning uh obviously has
been approved for that and we just um
concluding the tender exercise at the
moment so uh there is still some
question marked on whether that
um the building will be demolished or
not or whether there will be a temporary
stand put in or whether the new hotel
construction will be underway that will
be clear in the next few weeks
okay in that case can I ask why you need
a fifth concert well you know why you
need
so many concerts
the answer might be obvious but I'd like
you to just to outline really we we as I
say we don't know for definite that we
will want that one but we feel that a
man could be there and obviously the
club wants to uh maximize its his his
ability to
meet that demand basically
right I mean have you ever gone up to
the Limit as it is now with the four
concerts yeah we we've we've um
previously I've been at the club 28
years so I've seen every single concert
the the most we've done in a period was
was take that I can't remember the year
but we did five
um five concerts in in six nights um
right yeah well I'm struggling to
remember I live quite near the ground
but you're probably right it's probably
just my memory could could you just
outline for us why why you need to move
the access I know you've done it before
but um well this this there's two
factors the the Turning circle on on
Brian Statham way is is quite tight in
terms of coming in by the
um UA 92 building and the other
factories that we're we're anticipating
well we're hoping that the development
is going ahead and therefore there will
be extra
um construction traffic in that area
um that is working on the new
development
right and what just what uh well roughly
how many on each particular day how many
hgvs and what precise
the number will be I couldn't tell you
exact number but what we're planning to
do is to use the the stage that we put
in for the first concert will stay in
for the second stroke if there is this
exit concept that was that would be the
same stage used for that then that would
go out and a different stage come in for
the third and fourth dates you know the
the second to the Red Hot Chili Peppers
and the Foo Fighters so the number of
times we're not changing the stage four
or five times we're we're only changing
the stage twice
or using two stages okay in terms of the
gates on great Stone Road are you using
all the gates like there's 10 and 11
isn't their marks and yeah we would for
the heavy Goods Vehicles we would be
turning in there
um the ones by B and Q basically that
would be where we would be bringing them
in because there is almost a good area
for the lorries to pull in before they
actually come through the gates
right just just on that actually about
um two years maybe three years ago I
think it was before the pandemic there
was an incident I think where an hgv
struck the wall next to the gate I don't
know whether you're aware of that it's
like like at the B and Q
Century yes we were aware of that and it
and it was I mean what happened there
yeah
I think they just misjudged the the
Turning circle on it as they came in
you know but as far as I'm aware that's
the only incident we've ever had on on
that day Alice I don't know if you can
no that that's correct this year with
the amount of loading in and out through
that gate for Cricket and we have
similar sized trucks that load in
um for that so no that that is a very
rare occasion they're quite well trained
obviously so that is the only incident
that I can recall as well and that that
was for the cricket was it the the
building of the temporary stun was it
cool I can't honestly remember I do
remember that incident but we are we've
got so much going on on science hard to
remember when that particular incident
was and what which it was related what
is related to
okay can I discuss any of my colleagues
on the panel if they have any questions
for you just a couple of questions if I
may
um just for the for the record with the
the report quotes the figure of five
thousand as a capacity of more than five
thousand
um and that's because that's the figure
that
um
sort of triggers the requirement
um as I understand it so with just for
the record we are actually talking about
attendances in the vicinity of fifty
thousand that would be right would that
be the figure and I are you expecting or
working on a an attendance of 50 000 for
each of the events
um we'd like to to get towards that
figure with the if we have the
double-headed
um you know the same artist for both
nights that can sometimes lead to a
smaller number for both of those those
two nights we try and spread it out
evenly rather than have a bigger number
for one night and a smaller number for
the second night but it is just totally
based on demand
right so in in that situation you're not
sort of selling the 15th first
we sell the 15th first and then we would
only put put the 16th on if it was
selling very fast
um the promoter is very experienced in
knowing whether it would go to that
second day very quickly on the on the
day that it goes live on on sale and
they would then release that date
you know sometime on on that day
probably
right and I know we're not naming names
in this but presumably if you're looking
at somebody who can
um move a hundred thousand tickets in
one location
um it's going to be a big act and quite
a big attraction to Trafford yeah
definitely okay
um and um
a question about great Stone Road
um and the the
um
the actress that you see but the
restrictions that are there if my memory
serves me correct this is
May well be based in the fact that in it
dim and distant concert there was
um
de-rigging going on until the early
hours of the morning which caused a lot
of disturbance for local residents
without going to be correct with that
collection yeah I think I think that's
where the condition came in from yeah
so you're confident that you can police
that uh though the timing of of that
okay and I did have a question about the
dismantling or deconstructing but I
think you've covered that in in what you
said so it may well be that there are
only
to
um
this de-rigging
um sessions
rather than four really yeah but but the
individual acts will have some of their
own equipment
in terms of Lighting and Sound and
obviously the band or whatever those
that that equipment would would come in
as as normal but not in terms of
changing uh the whole structure
um dramatically between them and that's
apologies so just to add to that a lot
of the the trucks that do come in aren't
just delivering stage it is a lot of the
other infrastructure around site so
fencing toilets
etc those are the kind of things that
will stay on site throughout they won't
be moving so it it will just be
amendments to the stage and that change
of stage so those are a lot of the
trucks that come as well so that that
will be reduced once that that
infrastructure is on site as well okay
and just going back to those individual
acts and their uh their own individual
sets of equipment they will be policed
in the same respect in terms of the
timings of the of the access
um so we haven't got noise issues
and and what what there is obviously
time between each concept because we
have to change it round and clean the
site Etc so um when there's that change
over so we would ensure that that was
taking place we um we assured that Gates
when we have concert build and in
between concerts that gate will be man
24 hours but will be manned for managing
trucks between those hours as we have
done this year
okay and
um just a pedantic little question for
me to finish at this point with uh I
know it's not the football season but
you have you checked for clashes with
any events at Manchester United yes we
we've submitted
um as soon as we had the dates from the
promoter we submitted those obviously to
to yourself at chatford and to our
colleagues happy happy Manchester United
and
um we're going to be working with
um events um the the warehouse as well
just to ensure that they're aware well
we've informed those is is already in
terms of what what dates we've got in
for there
um but we've got a meeting in for next
week to further enhance that and
discussions with them about that
okay in fact that's it from me thank you
thank you thank you Council for working
councilor Brotherton do you have any
questions
yeah well Mike's question Mike's the
responses to Mike's question I've
answered most of mine really I was going
to ask about was it on the 16th but
obviously it is on the 16th and then
somebody mentioned to me about a clash
with women's football since I don't
follow football male or female
women's Euros I think you're talking
about yeah is that it well somebody
mentioned in the summer I don't exactly
know when exactly I I just obviously
what was how she said it probably it's
not within the June period when you're
thinking of having your concert
presumably
no and we as I say we have informed
United of it and they have none come
back with any any reason you know that
they see at the moment for any
difficulty with those days and in fact
we
a big plus up from our point of view is
that we work with them to use their car
parking as well so that that
um is a big help to us to be able to do
that
yeah that that's all I was looking at
last thank you chair okay thank you
thank you councilor brother Tim um can I
can I ask um Mr Pollock from
environmental health if he has any
questions for the African at this stage
uh no questions for me chair thank you
in that case would you like to
um speak to your submission regarding
the conditions
yeah uh thank you chair
thank you chair members of the licensing
uh subcommittee I think I think Claire
did uh did did runs through our the
progress that I think we've made over
over the last few days I would just like
to just confirm a little bit of
additional information
um so so the council's regulatory
Services uh we're aware of the host of
The Five concerts at the Cricket Club in
a two-week period commence on the 11th
of June may increase noise impacts on
local residents due to the short space
of time between concerts it is also the
case that Redevelopment Works taking
place around the venue May create some
additional areas of noise breakouts and
this needs to be reviewed and assessed
price taking place prior to concerts
taking in place
so to ensure that noise impacts on
residents during the concert period is
reduced officers have agreed the uh
conditions or schedule that has been
that has been provided to cover um some
enhanced noise mitigation particularly
focusing on those properties that are
most exposing noise on-trent Bridge work
and also to undertake uh noise modeling
to cover the situation of Redevelopment
and to potentially look at a wider
letter drop to ensure that residents
know what's happening and when hopefully
allow people to to be aware of what's
going on and to reduce
um to reduce complaints to the council
and and to to the club so it's a way
we're happy that with that without that
in place
um we don't have um any reason to to to
to touch objects two two to two is
requested
right so sorry you you've spoken to the
applicant about the the
extra condition
yes
um and he's quite happy to accept them
yeah this yes we we we've discussed
um the uh the the noise management plan
uh to be to focus on enhanced mitigation
for this uh kind of a more intense
period of concerts that that's going to
take place in 2022 so and for that to be
provided to the council uh for review
six weeks prior to the first event to be
held and this is how this has been
agreed but with the applicant yes
right in terms of the hgv access on
great Stone Road I believe this has been
happening for a while on the delegated
powers has there been any feedback on
that from the public or any complaints
or anything no I think I recall the um
the complaints that that you perhaps
referred to continue
it potentially is so just
I I'm not aware of any
problems in recent history it seems that
that that that that part of the process
seems to have been running as as
required uh in in in in recent recent
years so so again the the the the the
conditions uh that have been proposed
um again we're satisfied to actually
reduce the impact on residents
okay thank you Mr Pollock can I just ask
either of my colleagues have any
questions for you
no no I don't have any uh any questions
on on that thank you okay Mr Ash do you
have any questions of
Mr Pollock the environmental health
officer
no I don't we've we've had discussions
and and we're happy with what what's
proposed and we'll we'll be arranging a
meeting with the sound uh company that
that's been used for for many years
vanguardia early in the new year to to
to move that whole conversation forward
at an early stage
okay well the next step is I have to ask
uh parties to sum up which you've
probably already done but just just
formally
um if I can ask Mr Pollock first if
you'd like to come up
uh yes uh thank you chair and members of
the subcommittee uh to just to sum up
um uh we have agreed a way forward with
the applicants uh to reduce the impact
from noise on uh on local residents for
the uh the culture period that will take
place in 2022 and there will be uh noise
modeling taking place uh for for the
venue and uh a lot of drug strategy
being put in place which we which we
will review so so so
um we're happy this with this will uh
reduce impact on on residents and no no
further objections from me
do you wish to say anything in summation
no I think it's all been summarized very
well and as I say
um
we we do want to get that permission for
the for the fifth concert to have it a
past leave if we if we need to to do it
but it's not a foregone conclusion that
that will happen
okay so thank you Mr uh okay in that
case we're going to retire into a
breakout room to discuss
um the application
um and then we'll we'll come back in to
deliver the decision with reasons so
enough Natalie to
put us in the breakout room please yeah
but there's a point of clarification
that we'd like to ask Richard
from the environmental health Team
um we've only really had a chance to to
view the uh the new the new conditions
from the email on the 9th
um I mean it was sent prior to them
sorry during the meeting well uh Claire
was speaking but we didn't get a chance
to properly
look at it we noticed that the reference
to the
um 75 decibels is now this appeared from
paragraph
we just want to know what what what's
the significance of that
so the uh the current noise limit
that specified of the premises license
isn't it I think it's 23 to 37 Trent
Bridge Walk
um the the music noise must not breach
80 decibels over any 15 minutes
period so that that's what they have to
the engineers have to have to have to
um have to have to have to have to meet
so uh we got some feedback that if if
that was uh applied
uh across uh concerts then it's um you
pass
it would
potentially be not not make the concerts
not not viable basically I think that's
the feedback that we got that they would
perhaps struggle to uh to achieve that
that level so
um
so it's it's a character like that what
what we would want to do is to to to to
agree with uh the expert who works for
Lance cricket and enhanced noise
mitigation uh plan to see
what we can do and what what is possible
to reduce the noise as much as possible
at Trump Bridge Walk
right and and
what what I mean was that put in
specifically because some some of the
concerts are obviously midweed concerts
I.E school night and some of them are a
weekend Saturday was there any
consideration given to that difference
foreign
[Music]
midweek concerts
intended to to to to lead to increased
uh complaint levels because of
people so seven during term time kids
going to school uh workers having to get
up in in the morning so so that that
um definitely one of our considerations
and it's still it's still relevant when
we look for an enhanced
um noise mitigation and noise noise
management plan so the midweek is is
probably yes where we where we've got
most concern I would I would say and
um
that's why we've asked for
um additional enhanced mitigation where
possible
so so are you happy with that for well
it's now it's going to be 80 isn't it
which is what's in the original premises
license
that will be that that that limit will
will be there but what we've uh what
we've asked for is is a a a a mitigation
plan to be submitted for these uh
concerts to be to be agreed with us
so
um it would be expected that Cambridge
walk uh the properties there will get
some additional uh attention and we can
look to reduce it down as uh as much as
possible
is this going to be monitored over the
monitored over the period of the
transfers yeah so so when um when a
concert's held uh there is there's
always an officer from Council some
regulatory Services taking noise
measurements around the ground at the
required spots and this is usually in a
congruent with the um the noise
consultant appointed by uh Lancashire
okay thanks Richard does anybody else
have any questions for Richard
okay in that case we'll go back in the
breakout room and along with the support
supporting information
and also submission by Miss Mr poet the
environmental health officer
uh in respect of the fifth concert
requested in a 28-day period in in June
we are going to allow it
specifically for those dates
um subject to the conditions uh in Mr
poet's uh email the latest email now of
the ninth
um points one to three
uh and 0.1 relating to the noise
management plan
um will be something which which will be
agreed by the council and delegated uh
delegated to offices
um all this will be subject to a noise
monitoring report submitted 12 weeks
before the um the first concert begins
um in respect of the approval to use
great Stone Road entrance for hgbs we're
going to allow this and
um subjects to the the extra conditions
four to seven
uh in Mr Paul it's uh email of the night
which is which is today
um which we've decided are all relevant
uh conditions to the application
so this is specifically for those five
events uh next year
so that is the decision of the panel uh
which you will be receiving in writing
uh I believe within the next five days
um so before I close the meeting is
there is there any points of
clarification
that that you need to that you need to
know
that that's very clear thanks thanks
very much for your decision
okay Mr rush in that case I'll close the
meeting I thank everybody for the
participation and I wish you the very
best of luck with the the Consciousness
thank you very much thank you
all right bye thanks